you are watching cold Putin TV hi
welcome to another cold fusion video to
go go here today the smartphone is an
integral part of the lives of many
people around the world we're at the
start of a technological revolution the
revolution so rapid an advancement and
universal adoption that nothing like it
has ever been seen on the face of this
earth and I think by the end of this
production you might agree mobile
technology is the world's fastest
growing industry after all but with
growth this fast the question must be
asked are things starting to get a bit
stagnant and some markets the answer is
leaning towards yes for example in the
United States smartphone market
penetration went from a mere 18 percent
in the year 2010 to 72 percent just four
years later in 2014 so we're running out
of headroom here the market may be
beginning to saturate but that doesn't
mean the industry isn't going to
innovate I actually think the smartphone
industry is just getting warmed up and
many innovations await us so the big
question is where is this all going and
what is there in store for the future
well let's answer that today and take a
look at what the future may hold this
video will be broken up into three parts
in regards to the future of the
smartphone form function and performance
okay so let's begin
form I remember in the early 2010's when
people were talking about flexible
phones that could change their shape
depending on what you wanted to use it
for although it's nice to dream the
reality is a phone is one of the most
complex mass-produced consumer products
in history a typical phone includes
highly integrated circuits a wide array
of sensors and processes and not to
mention a battery that would explode if
you were to puncture it for a phone that
changes shape to happen the
manufacturing methods of internals would
have to be radically and fundamentally
changed until then a truly freeform
phone is still a pipe dream
a very nice one that being said I do see
curved screens like that on the galaxy
s6 edge or at least 2.5 D screens like
that in the iPhone 6 and original note 4
as becoming more commonplace really is
just a natural feeling for our fingers
and allows for extra functionality which
is always good for software designers to
stretch their creativity I also think
that front-facing speakers like that my
HTC m-series make perfect sense on large
screen phone tablets and as the form
factor finds its groove as a personal
entertainment device we could be seeing
more front-facing speakers in the future
okay so those are the basics of form
what about something revolutionary and
exciting enter modular designs so this
is the premise if phones are becoming or
already are mini computers why not just
have swappable parts like their desktop
for fathers initiatives like phonebloks
and project ara by google plan to do
just this instead of buying a brand new
phone every time you need to upgrade a
component now all you'd have to do is
just slot in a new module for that part
for example if your camera needs
upgrading just slot in a new one if your
screen breaks Slaven another one if you
need more ram or a faster processor no
problem if phone prices stay elevated as
they are now and phone product life
cycles stay at about one-year modular
phones may gain some market share in the
next five to ten years all right let's
move on to the next section function
this area has huge potential right now
today your phones can be used for almost
any casual task but the phones in the
future will be encompassing your entire
digital life anything from social media
presence to payment to even your
driver's license with the aid of cloud
computing and machine learning the
healthcare industry will also be
impacted by giving more control to the
patient The Wall Street Journal did a
report on the future of healthcare
through mobile technology in this report
a working example of the future was
given by cardiologist Eric Topol and
goes as follows I quote let's say you
have a rash that you need examined you
could snap a picture of it with your
smartphone and download an app to
process the image within minutes a
dedicated computer algorithm
text to your diagnosis the message could
include next steps such as recommending
a topical ointment or a visit to a
dermatologist for further assessment he
goes on to say that smartphone users
will be able to perform physical exams
on themselves apps are already being
developed to handle all aspects of the
eye the throat and oral cavity and the
lungs and heart he goes on to say that
in the next 10 years nanotechnology in
the bloodstream could allow for phones
to constantly monitor all of our organs
for something like the very early signs
of cancer so that's a pretty interesting
concept to think about all right so
let's move one of it let's talk about
mobile virtual reality I'm predicting
that it's going to be huge in the future
with an entire spin-off industry just
for this niche mobile VR totally makes
sense in a serendipitous way since there
are already no wise as compared to
today's early V RPC methods all you
would really need is a wireless gaming
controller and you could probably get a
somewhat immersive experience anywhere
anytime you help you manage wires while
you're playing that's why we love the
gear VR think it's a great advise and
you're right in fact you're not better
gives you that extra feeling of freedom
much more Martha although mobile VR
games will probably be simpler than the
PC counterparts there's still plenty of
potential here so that's pretty cool but
what about the future of mobile software
as it turns out within the mobile
industry the flow of capital is already
slowly starting to go from the hardware
into the software development so with
more money we're bound to get better
apps for a wider reach of uses more
advanced applications are a great thing
but at the end of the day these apps
have to run on an operating system and I
think many of you would agree that
there's still a lot of room for
improvement there of course sure Android
5.0 and iOS 8 are pretty great but
they're kind of basic when you compare
them to Mac OS or Windows 10 and even
basic when you compare them to what
smartphones might require in the future
in my opinion in the future I think
we'll start to see mobile software that
supports full desktop working
environments with integrated support for
a keyboard mouse and external desktop
monitor all your work and data will be
synced to the cloud so the main idea is
that you can get your work done anywhere
anytime with absolutely no restrictions
this idea of the PC and phone coming
together may sound familiar to some of
you out there and that's because it's
been done before by Ubuntu Ubuntu had
the right vision with their mobile PC
conversion software but they had arrived
way too early the market still isn't
ready and neither is the consumer
alright so let's move on in terms of
battery life today's battery life will
be a joke there are already numerous
battery technologies that are on their
way up such as graphene and silicon
energy storage and organic batteries
from companies such as store dot if
these technologies don't get suppressed
we should be in for a treat in terms of
longer-lasting devices we're talking ten
times the energy density and a battery
life of weeks instead of a day or so
this can only happen if a free-market
environment exists that fire in the
future
before we finish off this section I just
want to touch on one last thing cameras
phone cameras definitely have a lot of
room for improvement and I think in five
years they'll be much better than they
are today perhaps 40 megapixels are
standard some pretty good depth of field
superior low-light performance and one
thing that I think is going to really
increase is the capacity for high speed
I'm talking in the tens of thousands of
frames here and of course super HD
videorecording like 6k and above all
right saw almost done let's move on to
the last section performance in previous
videos whenever I've talked about mobile
performance and how its doubling every
year and currently sits on the level of
about a 2005 PC it seems to cause a bit
of controversy even with hard numbers
but today this concept goes a bit
further with the Tegra x1 but we'll get
to that in a second
first a little bit of what could be
coming in terms of mobile power I think
that 2016 to 2017 will probably be the
years of truly capable gaming mobile
hardware today we're already starting to
see glimpses of that take the NVIDIA
Tegra x1 as a case study this so-called
mobile super chip has 256 graphics cores
eight processing cores and can generate
4k video as sixty Hertz not to mention
that it can run the cutting-edge game
engines that today's PC is always run is
that amazing guys oh that was not a
video that was all run in real time you
were seeing Unreal Engine 4 running
elemental the demo done by epic
everything was done in high dynamic
range lighting which basically means
each one of the pixels the RGB are all
floating-point exactly the same engine
that runs on a high-end PC exactly the
same engine that runs and a
next-generation game console Tegra x1
just two years ago to perform feats less
than half as impressive took 300 watts
of power and today with the x1 it just
takes 10 watts
according to Nvidia CEO Jason Wong the
Tegra x1 can run at 1 teraflop
ok so what you might be thinking well
let's put that into perspective this is
the supercomputer ASC I read it became
fully operational in the year 1997 and
was the first supercomputer to reach 1
teraflop
and it held that record till the year
2000 this computer took up a large room
and required 10,000 pentium pros to run
and yeast 1 million watts and
as you know today in 2015 we can reach a
similar performance on a mobile chip and
next year this performance is set to
double again are you starting to see the
picture of progress now it's all truly
incredible okay so how's this happening
and how can mobile ships be moving so
fast almost walls apart from where they
were in just 2012 well the answer comes
in two words research money the
smartphone industry as I've said
numerous times is huge it's a booming
market that is sustained by a massive
revenues coming in each quarter all
mobile chip manufacturers have a clear
motive to spend large amounts of
research and development money and when
colossal amounts of money is spent in
research alone what people thought was
impossible four years ago becomes a
reality but some of you guys or
technologically inclined will be asking
wouldn't we be running into heat issues
are we going to hit a brick wall in
terms of how many transistors we can fit
on there and these are very good
questions as it turns out some
researchers are saying that we're only a
couple of years away from getting around
such issues so assuming that we
circumvent current manufacturing limits
in about five to ten years time we will
definitely end up with phones that are
as powerful as today's desktops and just
to be clear this doesn't mean that one
day everyone's just going to wake up and
the PC has been replaced by a smartphone
all I'm saying is that the smart phone
of the future will be as powerful as a
PC today PCs will always have
specialized uses in conclusion the
mobile industry is like nothing we've
ever seen before
and because of this we are living in a
truly incredible time I hope this video
has sparks your imagination a little bit
and I trust that you learnt some new
information anyway thanks for watching
and as usual don't forget to share this
with a friend and subscribe if you're
new and want to see some more cool stuff
hey guys to going in here thanks for
watching the whole way through my video
it was just a little bit of a fun look
at what the future of mobile technology
could actually bring so I hope you
enjoyed it and got something out of that
and and yeah but it was just a bit of
what could be in store for the future so
anyway I let you guys go and thanks for
watching don't forget to do a thumbs up
if you liked it share with a friend
anything they'll be interested and
subscribe if you thanks guys
cold future its me thinking